so you new to America like Paul how's it
paulus from South Africa listen to how
she says I'm gonna put a sausage on the
grill I'm gonna put some booty on the
pie spooky this time of year people like
polar ask themselves so what's the deal
with Halloween in America ha ha ha I'll
tell you Halloween is all about fear and
candy think of President Donald Trump
eating a Snickers bar but doesn't
Halloween have its roots in pagan
folklore silence maybe but if you
foreigners want a real fright follow
these simple guidelines and you'll fit
seamlessly into any American monster
bash first there's pumpkins you need a
pumpkin but I heard that
jack-o'-lanterns originated in Ireland
and they coughed turnips not pumpkins to
ward off the spirits no no Paula you'll
need a knife no a special knife Oh with
practice you'll be carving pumpkins in
no time actually what kind of looks like
Hakurei next you'll need inspires
converse and things that sound like this
I just worked hurry you want to know
what's really scary Americans spend over
6 billion dollars every year on
Halloween Paula it's Halloween not an
economics class now come the costumes oh
yeah in Celtic folklore the superstition
was that if you dressed up as a ghost
you might fool the evil spirits into
thinking you one of them so they
wouldn't take your soul you're not
fooling anyone stuff I forgot now his
costumes all about sexy sexy Captain
America sexy witch sexy monster octopus
looking good monster pony finally
there's trick-or-treating okay so I
definitely know this one in the Middle
Ages children would go door-to-door
begging for food or money in exchange
for prayers and that's trick-or-treating
oh it's the day you can walk onto a
stranger's property in America ring
their doorbell and not get shot really
probably you probably want a child
though what if I want to give them
something a little healthier like
raisins what if I ran out of candy what
if the kids look too old to be
trick-or-treating
silence pause you'll never true older
trick-or-treat stop yelling at me would
you sir merry Halloween damn it Paul